keita france bonjour dernière et vos
jours bernard 38 degrés ce matin à la
pointer profitant de les détailler
encore là pour les poser nos cultes sur
la place
[Musique]
de paris s'attend
à ton âge avec la canicule la faut
s'hydrater toutes les heures
tes collègues cd complet vous sentez pas
tu peux un expert mais pour moi ça sent
la merde savez ce que je pense les
parisiennes et les parisiens
[Musique]
quatre mètres 7 5 fermer les plages mais
je te laisse une semaine et jean
personne d'autre à la brigade cette
baignade interdite la probabilité mouche
une fois
j'ai un requin trappeur petit
peu une espèce protégée on va encore
dire que l'écologie c'est l'apanage des
verts du tout écoute ça fait 25 ans que
tu roule au diesel
[Musique]